nos han dicho que el coseno de 58 grados
es aproximadamente 0.53 y es
aproximadamente porque los decimales
siguen y siguen solo que lo redondea a
dos decimales y ahora nos preguntan cuál
es el seno de 32 grados y los incitó a
detener el vídeo e intentarlo por su
cuenta una pista es que vean este
triángulo rectángulo donde uno de los
ángulos ya está etiquetado con 32 grados
encuentra en los demás ángulos del
triángulo y utilicen las definiciones
fundamentales las definiciones soca tohá
y vean si pueden encontrar el valor del
seno de 32 grados
bueno asumo que ya realizaron un intento
por resolverlo así que intentemos
resolverlo ahora
entonces sabemos que la suma de los
ángulos de un triángulo es 180 grados y
el ángulo de la derecha es un ángulo de
90 grados y eso significa que la suma de
los otros dos deberá de ser 90 grados
estos dos suman 90 más otros 90 serán
180 grados
otra manera de verlo es que los otros
dos ángulos no rectos tendrán que ser
ángulos complementarios entonces que
sumando a 32 da 90 pues 90 menos 32 58
entonces esto de aquí será 58 grados por
qué es esto interesante pues porque de
antemano sabemos cuánto vale el coseno
de 58 grados veámoslo desde la
perspectiva de las relaciones de la
longitud de los lados de un triángulo
rectángulo
escribamos soca toa seno es opuesto
sobre hipotenusa acá
jose no es adyacente sobre hipotenusa
tohá tangente es opuesto sobre adyacente
entonces podemos escribir el coseno de
58 grados que ya lo sabemos si lo vemos
en términos de las razones fundamentales
coseno es adyacente sobre hipotenusa
este es el ángulo de 58 grados y el lado
que es adyacente a él es hagámoslo en
este color es el lado de ese que está
justo aquí
es uno de los lados que conforman este
ángulo es el que no es la hipotenusa
esta de aquí es la hipotenusa
entonces este será el adyacente la
longitud del lado adyacente bc sobre la
longitud de la hipotenusa sobre la
longitud de la hipotenusa
la longitud de la hipotenusa es a b
ahora pensemos en cómo representar el
seno de 32 grados
entonces el seno c
32 grados
bueno ese no es su puesto sobre
hipotenusa entonces nos enfocaremos en
este ángulo de 32 grados
cuál es su lado opuesto resulta ser b c
vemos que es
solo como eso sobre la hipotenusa sobre
lo que es la longitud de la hipotenusa a
b es a b
fijémonos que el seno de 32 grados es
veces sobre ave y el coseno de 58 grados
es veces sobre ave otra manera de verlo
es que el seno de este ángulo es lo
mismo que el coseno de este otro ángulo
entonces podemos escribir literalmente
que el seno
seno
grados
es igual a coseno de 58 grados
que es aproximadamente igual a 0.53
y esta es una propiedad realmente útil
el seno de un ángulo es igual al coseno
de su complemento entonces podemos
escribir esto en términos generales
podemos escribir que el seno
de un ángulo es igual al coseno
y su complemento es igual al coseno de
- teta piénselo puede haber cambiado por
completo este problema en vez de que
fuera un seno de 32 grados pude haber
hecho el seno de 25 grados y si alguien
nos hubiera dado el coce note cuánto es
90 menos 25 si alguien nos hubiera dado
el coseno de 65 grados podemos haber
visto esto como 25 el complemento estará
exactamente aquí este sería 65 grados y
podemos utilizar exactamente la misma
idea